wer gedacht hat der streit zwischen spd
und union für die kandidatur ursula von
der leyens für das amt der
kommissionspräsident in brüssel werde
sich langsam beruhigen
der hat sich getäuscht im gegenteil
nachdem zunächst die spd gegen die
personalie angerannt war schlägt jetzt
die cdu zurück
etwas ruhiger im ton die partei
vorsitzende annegret kramp karrenbauer
die davor warnt dass es zu krisenhaften
entwicklungen in europa kommen könnte
sollte von der leyen tatsächlich nicht
gerät werden im europäischen parlament
kommen dann etwas rüder die herren der
schöpfung hinterher volker bouffier der
hessische ministerpräsident und
stellvertretende cdu vorsitzende hat der
faz gesagt wenn die spd ist denn nun so
halten wolle wie ihr ehemaliger
vorsitzender sigmar gabriel vor schlägt
nämlich wegen der von allein kandidatur
die koalition zu verlassen dann geht
doch deutlich wurde auch
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble
er sagte so zitat lamarr schicht dürfe
man in europa wegen einer personalie
nicht weitermachen von der leyen müsse
gewählt werden selbst wenn das verfahren
vielleicht noch verbesserungswürdig sei
also ist zeigt sich hier gibt es echte
sorge in unionskreisen dass die
kandidatur von der leyens schief gehen
könne
sollte das mitte des monats im
europäischen parlament tatsächlich so
kommen und sollte es am ende sogar an
den fehlenden stimmen deutschen
sozialdemokraten liegen so kann man sich
leicht vorstellen dass der jetzige
streit zwischen den koalitionspartnern
nur ein laues lüftchen gewesen ist im
vergleich zu dem was dann auf die
koalition zukommt es könnte eine
existenzielle krise werden